got some breaking news for you now this  is concerning  harvey weinstein the crown prosecution  service has today authorized the  metropolitan police to charge harvey  weinstein with two counts of indecent  assault against a woman in august 1999  they say charges have been authorized  against harvey weinstein age 70  following a review of the evidence  gathered by the met in its investigation  the cps reminds all concerned that  criminal proceedings against the  defendant are active and that he has the  right to a fair trial  so that's the cps uh deciding that the  metropolitan police can proceed with  charges against weinstein of two counts  of indecent assault against a woman in  august  1996 that's all the details we have at  the moment harvey weinstein of course  serving a prison sentence in america  currently i will have more on that here  on sky news as we get it